[Musique]
José Legault Sébastien Bavet Michel
David bonsoir
bonsoir je pense je vais me permettre
une dernière fois de souhaiter bonne
année moi d'habitude au 3 4 c'est fini
mais là vous êtes précieux bonne année
bonne année à vous aussi bonne année
Patrice
vous écriviez là-dessus José vous avez
écrit des milliards de fois là-dessus
Sébastien vous envoyez d'ailleurs à
l'autre vous avez envoyé une note
sur ce qui se passe à
Maisonneuve-Rosemont on a dû à peu près
fermer l'urgence c'est de ceux qui
étaient là on les a pas ils ont laissé
là on s'en est occuper mais on a
détourné les ambulances la nuit dernière
l'urgence est ouverte cette nuit
toujours est-il que le problème n'est
pas réglé on écoute le ministre et
Vincent Maricel on vient
le vrai problème c'est pas juste le TSO
c'est qui manque tout le temps de monde
ici et il y a une raison fondamentale à
ça c'est que les gouvernements
successifs y compris celui qu'on a de la
CAQ maintenant ont complètement
abandonné l'est de Montréal puis on
abandonné l'hôpital maison
neuve-rosemont de toute façon rien
qu'avoir on voit bien là ça tient avec
de la broche ce là il va avoir 70
ans l'an prochain il est inadéquat il
est dangereux évidemment il est pas
attractif pour le personnel qui préfère
aller travailler dans les hôpitaux neufs
ou dans des cliniques neuves je les
comprends
alors mais en oeuvre Rosemont problème
particulier problème plus général TSO
etc chef David est-ce qu'on va voir le
bout du tunnel et quand monsieur Dubé
dit oubliez pas on est en pleine négo
est-ce que ça joue d'après vous oui non
ce problème là ça fait au moins 10
conventions collective là qui ont été
signés et des négociations donc
depuis que le problème existe et d'une
convention à l'autre ça change rien
d'ailleurs je vous signale que le temps
supplémentaire obligatoire là qui est
tellement décréé et avec raison il est
inclus dans les conventions c'est à dire
qu'il est prévu que si on en a vraiment
besoin on peut y avoir recours de là à
devenir un mode de gestion parce que
c'est souvent le cas ce n'est pas c'est
une autre paire de manche alors je
comprends que c'est un enjeu de
négociation mais c'est je pense pas
qu'on peut s'attribuer ça au fait une
nouvelle ronde de négociation commence
écouter monsieur Dubé disait tantôt
c'est pas normal que comme ça tout d'un
coup on décide de fermer une urgence
sans préavis mais c'est pas normal non
plus que des gens se fassent dire
régulièrement toutes les semaines sans
préavis tu vas travailler encore même si
ton corps est fini alors c'est ce qu'on
comprend que laisse de Montréal il y a
une situation particulière mais on
trouve le même problème à Jonquières les
choses
alors ça dépend largement le cas de
l'Est de Montréal et Sébastien Bavet on
est devant un vrai cercle vicieux il y a
des postes qu'on ouvre et c'est le cas à
Maisonneuve-Rosemont qui ne sont pas
comblés parce que les gens se disent les
infirmières se disent puis nous le
disent non on veut pas aller sur un
poste régulier parce que si je vais si
j'obtiens ce poste là je vais être
obligé peut-être de faire du temps
supplémentaire j'aime mieux rester sur
numéraire j'aime mieux aller ailleurs
c'est ça le cercle vicieux le pied tant
qu'il y a pas de gens qui arrivent on
est obligé de demander du temps
supplémentaire voilà et c'est la pénurie
de main qui explique en grande partie
c'est ce recours autant supplémentaire
obligatoire en fait pénurie de main
d'oeuvre faut la relativiser dans la
mesure où il y a jamais eu autant
d'infirmière au Québec on produit entre
guillemets ou on fait graduer chaque
année des centaines d'infirmières pour
aller dans le réseau mais les besoins
sont de plus en plus importants parce
que la population vieillit et vous avez
des infirmières qui se retrouvent à bout
de souffle et qui se font demander de
faire deux corps consécutifs alors en
effet tant qu'on comble pas ses postes à
temps plein on n'a pas les ressources
suffisantes pour
réussir à donner le service le problème
des corps à temps plein c'est d'où des
postes à temps plein c'est que les
infirmières pensent qu'elles tombent
dans un cercle vicieux de se faire
demander toujours du temps
supplémentaire obligatoire lorsqu'elle
s'occupent ces postes là elles veulent
selon ce que je comprends parfois une
certaine liberté d'être peut-être à
temps partiel plutôt que d'occuper ces
temps-là pour pouvoir pallier justement
au fait que on leur demande parfois même
quand elles sont en temps partiel de
faire deux quarts de travail successives
mais ça c'est énorme comme problème bon
José votre vision
oh mon dieu je pense qu'on paye le prix
pour
des trois dernières décennies là où à
tous les gouvernements ont laissé deux
phénomènes
qui se sont nourris le l'autre là
vraiment pulluler c'est à dire bon
justement d'avoir des conditions de
travail dans le réseau public de santé
qui ne sont pas optimales disons-le
comme ça diplomatiquement et laisser les
agences privées évidemment prendre de
l'expansion amen le personnel du public
qui finalement
occupé en grande partie et là le vrai
cercle vicieux il est là il est dans le
public qui prie avec une mauvaise
gestion de ses ressources humaines des
ressources humaines qui s'en vont privés
qu'il a encouragé lui-même il est obligé
d'aller payer à Grand Prix des
infirmières et d'autres types de
personnels dans les agences privées pour
essayer de les ramener au public écouter
si la maison qui rend fou et ça c'est
parce qu'on a vraiment
parce que Christian Dubé rappelez-vous
un moment donné il avait dit après la
pandémie s'il y a des gestionnaires qui
sont incompétents dans le réseau de la
santé on va aller tasser et ça inclut
les PDG des 6 et des six aujourd'hui il
a choisi de ne pas taper sur la tête du
PDG du Sud ce qu'on me dit c'est que on
est satisfait des efforts qui le fait
pour l'Hôpital Maisonneuve-Rosemont et
du plan qui met en place pour essayer de
régler le problème donc c'est implicite
sans que Christian Dubé dit je fais
confiance au PDG du Sud sans dire qu'il
ne lui faisait plus confiance il a donc
implicitement intérêt sa confiance
envers le PDG et c'est intéressant parce
que on continue à lui faire confiance et
on ne le tient pas responsable de la
situation qu'il y a actuellement à
maison neuve heureusement est-ce que les
syndicapés non non je les ai est-ce que
les syndicats ont une part de
responsabilité aussi ou dans votre
esprit pas du tout
Michel
certains que les syndicats doivent dans
la mesure du raisonnable je vous dirais
faire preuve de flexibilité mais il y a
un moment donné où quand on a
l'impression que qu'on se fait avoir
dans le système et que malgré des
promesses répétées année après année il
y a rien qui change je comprends que la
patience peut commencer à être épuisé
alors moi je pense que l'on peut pas
tenir le le PDG ducius pas plus que le
syndicat d'un problème de sous capacité
dans le cas de Maisonneuve-Rosemont qui
dure depuis des années et qui est pas la
faute ni du syndicat ni du gestionnaire
écoutez souvenez-vous il y a 15-20 ans
on parlait déjà d'un problème lors du
débat sur l'emplacement du Sud en des
gens voulaient l'envoyer sur le site de
la gage de triage à Outremont et déjà on
disait non non il faut pas parce qu'il y
a une sous capacité hospitalière dans
l'est de Montréal mais toujours là 15
ans plus tard la sous capacité pas été
réglé alors ça c'est pas la faute du
syndicat ni la faute d'ailleurs du PDG
ducius oui José là-dessus est peut-être
ajouté l'élément de l'Est de Montréal
parce que quand Vincent Maricel dit
c'est pas très attractif il y a on le
voit il y a le chute oui il y a des
difficultés ailleurs mais elles sont
plus prononcées encore à
Maisonneuve-Rosemont
mais tout est toujours plus prononcé
mais à l'aise de Montréal de toute
évidence ce sont des populations qui
sont souvent des laissés par les
gouvernements quels qu'ils soient et
l'histoire de Maisonneuve-Rosemont est
un véritable scandale quand même là on a
en Europe on a des hôpitaux qui ont qui
ont deux trois quatre siècles qui ont
été bien entretenus ici il y a vraiment
eu une culture de négligence et aussi
tout se retard qui est pris pour
une rénovation ou une reconstruction
écoutez moi j'ai mis les pieds au sum
pour la première fois là dans une
chambre en allant visiter quelqu'un il y
a quelques semaines écouter je suis
tombé des Nucci quand je comparais ça à
la maison en oeuvre Rosemont ou même à
Notre-Dame et là je parle pas de la
qualité des soins là je parle pas de la
qualité des soignants je parle
l'environnement la vie de suscité le
danger pour les les nosocomiales les
infections les bactéries etc dans les
vieux hôpitaux c'est terrible vous
arrivez au Chine vous avez l'impression
d'être
ils utilisent même les textos pour quand
on a des prises de sang mais là c'est
autre chose ah bon
c'est impeccable alors quand on parle
d'attractions de lieu de travail aussi
mais de sécurité des patients de
sécurité du personnel la vie tu sais un
hôpital ça met en danger la santé de
tout le monde on va en parler parce
qu'on va malheureusement reparler mais
je veux je veux vous dire un mot sur la
rencontre le goût du M on écoute
monsieur Duhem à sa sortie et on revient
en parler
rapidement bon j'ai toujours pas de
place à l'Assemblée nationale seul
là-dessus il y a pas changé alors on est
dans cette dans ce carrousel de
rencontre plutôt sympathique Sébastien
qui se poursuit c'est intéressant pour
Eric Djem le fait qu'il soit inclus dans
ce carrousel c'est à dire qu'il
participe à la ronde de discussion avec
le Premier ministre parce que ils
étaient très frustrés les gens du Parti
conservateur de se faire refuser l'accès
à l'Assemblée nationale à ériger en
particulier ce qui demandait ce qu'un
ordinateur un local puis l'accès aux
salles de conférence de presse et
monsieur Legault était pas chaud à cette
idée là là le fait de le voir ce soir en
face du premier ministre ça le légitime
d'une certaine façon dans son
identité politique ou dans son existence
politique sur l'échiquier politique
alors c'est intéressant le paradoxe qui
peut y avoir son absence à l'Assemblée
nationale mais sa présence devant le
Premier ministre pour le reste ils sont
à des années lumière sur certains
dossiers le gaz naturel par exemple
monsieur Legault a une époque était pour
il est il n'est plus en faveur du
développement de cette filière notamment
GNL Québec alors que Eric duham pousse
pour ça j'ai terminé en vous disant que
Monsieur James aborde ses rencontres en
se disant monsieur le Gauvain veut se
positionner comme étant le modéré avec à
sa droite
Eric duem à sa gauche Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois et de prendre des positions qui
sont entre les deux et donc de gouverner
au centre et presque au-dessus de la
mairie même il rêve d'un deuxième mandat
presque au-dessus de la mêlée Michel
David ouais ben je pense que des ketchup
de position c'est effectivement monsieur
Duhem qui avait le plus d'avantage à
obtenir de ces rencontres là pour les
raisons qu'on convient d'expliquer ça le
légitimise passablement avec lui qui a
pas de député à l'Assemblée nationale
elle est quand même reconnu comme un
interlocuteur valable par le Premier
ministre pour ce qui est des autres moi
je pense que tout le profit de ces
rencontres là ou presque et pour
monsieur Legault qui est qui on comprend
qu'il a voulu réagir aux critiques là
sur les distorsions du du mode de
scrutin et puis des résultats de la
dernière élection mais c'est lui
scolaire du de l'homme ouvert et ça
l'engage strictement rien il voit les
écouter mais ne vous en faites pas c'est
un peu comme dans la pandémie il mettra
personne dans le secret des dieux le cas
il va avoir une décision difficile à
prendre la puis il va pas les informer
de ses intentions d'avance alors je
comprends qu'on peut pas être contre la
vertu puis qu'il faut que tout le monde
se parle mais il y en a un qui est plus
avantagé que d'autres dans l'exercice
ouais José conclusion oui je suis bien
d'accord d'ailleurs pendant la campagne
électorale j'ai remarqué que le bossword
ou l'expression préférée de Monsieur
Lego c'était je suis ouvert à ne jamais
s'engager à quoi que ce soit donc il y
avait c'est exactement la même attitude
mais je dirais que pour Monsieur DM
monsieur le goût avantage aussi malgré
tout à bien le traiter parce que il faut
qu'il entretienne aussi cette division
de l'opposition là plus il y a une
partie de position même si Monsieur
Dumas siège à l'Assemblée nationale plus
ça favorise à café bien entendu José
Sébastien Michel merci beaucoup à très
bientôt au revoir en soirée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI